SETH LADD: Welcome everybody,
to Dartisans episode 14.
Today we turn the spotlight over
to our community members
to see some cool demos and hear
some of their stories.
But first, let's welcome my
co-host, JJ, welcome.
JJ BEHRENS: Howdy.
SETH LADD: John, thanks
for coming.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Hello.
SETH LADD: And let's start
off with some news.
So the two books that we're
aware of, "Dart Up and
Running" and "Dart in Action"
are now going to press, which
is awesome.
So look for those on your
favorite online book retailer
or bookstore.
JJ BEHRENS: "Dart for
Hipsters" not
going to press yet?
SETH LADD: Already
been in press.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh wow.
I'm impressed.
SETH LADD: Haha
[DRUM FILL SOUND].
And actually, that's a good
segue because Chris Strong,
who is the author of "Dart for
Hipsters," has now picked up
blogging again on Dart.
He is back, although he'll
say he never really left.
So we welcome Chris again
to his blogs about Dart.
For instance, he's been updating
his hipster MVC
framework with the M1 syntax.
So you can follow along with
what Chris is doing there.
On the speaking front, Dart will
be a code mash in early
January in Sandusky, Ohio.
Now this is cool because it
is an indoor water park.
JJ BEHRENS: That's awesome.
SETH LADD: Yes.
I don't know how we're ever
going to get anything done at
this conference, but I'm coming
with my swim trunks.
JJ BEHRENS: Why did I not get
invited to this conference?
SETH LADD: And we'll also be
at DevOps in November, and
Rich Web Experience, excuse
me, also in November.
So lots of places.
JJ, any upcoming talks?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I have JS camp
Asia in Singapore, and I
have [SPEAKING SPANISH]
in Mexico.
And I'm really working on
my Spanish for that one.
SETH LADD: Awesome, awesome.
JJ BEHRENS: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
SETH LADD: And later in this
week, actually, I think a
little bit closer to
home, John, there's
DrinkUp in San Francisco?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
this next Thursday.
SETH LADD: OK, and do you have
any details about this?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Not the
specifics right now, but it'll
be in San Francisco, around
7:00 PM next Thursday, and
we'll send out a public
invite on G+ too.
SETH LADD: Awesome, awesome.
So if you're in the
Bay Area, stop by.
This is a DrinkUp to support
and celebrate the
M1 release of Dart.
And it's put on by the Dart
SF meet up group.
And about every other month,
they do presentations.
And then the alternate months,
they do these more social
DrinkUps and Meetups, which
is really cool.
We relaunched our presentations
and slides page
on dartlang.org.
And so you can see nice full
color graphics of all the
videos and the slides and PDFs
that we're aware of, put on by
the Dart team.
And also on YouTube, the Google
Developers channel, we
have a Dart playlist where we
feature videos from throughout
the community, the ones
that we notice.
And so lots of good ways to keep
up with the presentations
that we have done in the past.
And we'll continue to
update with the ones
we'll do in the future.
The editor continues their
solid cadence of releases
almost every week.
Some of the features I really
love from this release are
more clean ups.
Now the code cleanups are
fantastic because, as we rev
the Dart language, how
do you maintain and
keep up your old code?
How do you make it compliant
with M1?
Well, the editor can actually
do this for you.
And so it can do the syntactic
transformations.
And other, just, cleanups
in general, that
keep you up to date.
And they've added more, like
removing the abstract keyword
from empty methods.
So the editor can do these
kind of cleanups for you.
JJ BEHRENS: Dude, the editor
team just like kicks butt.
They're, like, solid.
SETH LADD: Super solid
velocity of the team.
So now with the editor's auto
update, you'll get all these
new features as well.
So try out the clean up to keep
updated with all your
code syntax and libraries.
A lot of cool videos, actually,
have come out from
the Goto conference in Aarhus,
which seems to be a very good
language and virtual
machine conference.
But Lars Bach and, I hope I
get the name right, Anders
Haalsberg, I hope I
got that correct--
they have a great discussion
posted to Channel 9,
Microsoft's equivalent to GDL.
And Glen Brock and Erik Meyer,
I hope I got that correct,
have another great discussion
as well.
And these are posted
on Channel 9.
So if you're interested more
about just language designs,
[? function ?] machine designs,
compiling the
JavaScript--
some good stuff there.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
SETH LADD: Moving back over to
the community, Victor Savkin
continues with DartCast.
So he has dartcast.com, which is
really cool, and he's done
three screen casts already about
just various features of
the editor or the language.
So we are really excited to
see what he's doing there.
And if you want to see more,
just short how-to videos with
Dart, check out dartcast.com.
Speaking of victories, also
working on a data binding
library for Dart.
This one uses mirrors.
And so this is probably a good
time to clarify our qualify,
the use of mirrors is right now
really a VM only future.
I'm not exactly sure how and
when we'll get into Dart to
JS, but I think working in
the VM is good first.
We can explore the API and get
it really solid for that too.
There's a group of Dartisans
in Lithuania who have been
translating the dartlang.org
site, which is
really cool to see.
And they reached out and asked
if they can do that, and of
course we said yes.
And this is really just a call
to action to communities all
over the globe-- if there's
stuff you want to translate or
get localized for your
community, we're here to
support you.
And thanks to the Lithuanian
Dartisans for that.
John Evans, one of our solid
Windows users, has confirmed
that dart editor pub, et cetera,
is working on Windows
8, I'm which is great.
So if you've updated to the
latest version of Windows,
John's confirming that our Dart
tools seem to work just
fine there.
So that's really good to hear.
Bernard [? Pitular ?]
has been playing with Web
Audio API and Dart.
Now, Bernard is working on the
Dart flash library, which is
really cool. have you
guys seen this?
JJ BEHRENS: I'm going to focus
on that right around December.
Actually, I'm going to do a lot
of work with ActionScript
developers.
SETH LADD: There seems to be a
lot of familiarity there with
ActionScript 3 developers
and Dart.
And Bernard really keyed off of
that kind of early on, has
been working on this API library
to make it easier for
people from an ActionScript 3
background to work with Dart.
And so if you want to learn
to play "Hey Jude" in the
browser, check out his
latest experiment.
It's really fun.
I want a special call
out to Blossom.
It's a new startup in the Bay
Area working on lean project
management.
And they recently had a blog
post about using Dart in
production in their stack,
which is really cool.
So I don't have too many
details, but they listed a lot
of common projects like, if I
remember, NodeJS, and Dart,
and so it seems like they have
a good kind of polyglot
production stack,
which is cool.
So check out that
to learn more.
And this is actually a pretty
good segue into our guest, but
Kevin Moore has released his
first straw man, first test
around a Dart build system
he's calling Hop.
And it's a call for comments to
see what kind of experience
that you would like.
And you can find this--
I don't know if you can find
this, but you can find many
libraries we've talking
about, and hopefully
Hop soon, on Pub.
And so I want to lead in today
with just showing off our
package manager.
So I'm going to go ahead and
share my screen here.
OK.
So we've done a lot about
community today.
And we're going to need some of
our community guests just
here in a moment.
But where is really
this the focal
point of the Dart community?
Well, I think it's one pub,
our package manager.
We have called that
pub.dartling.org, hopefully
you guys can see
that coming in.
No?
Hmm.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Looks
a little blurry.
SETH LADD: Sorry, we're having
technical difficulties here
with the font here.
I'm going to try stop screen
sharing here for just a
moment, and we'll
try it again.
JJ BEHRENS: So it's kind of
interesting how he called the
build system Hop.
I would've guessed that he would
have gone after Dake,
you know, for Dart Make.
SETH LADD: That's a good
question for Kevin.
We'll ask him in a moment.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, so there was
a programming language called
Brain Fuck.
And I actually built build
system for Brain Fuck.
And I made it so that you had to
put spaces before the tabs
in order to denote the execution
block because you
simply differentiating between
spaces and tabs wasn't enough.
I thought like invisible spaces
would actually be funnier.
SETH LADD: Let's see
what happens here.
Is it any better now, guys?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Wow, that's
unfortunate that the text is
really coming out garbled.
SETH LADD: OK, I'm going
full screen.
Does that help?
Negative.
OK, you know what?
We're just going to move on.
We're going to just talk
about Pub, and I'll
stop our screen sharing.
Hopefully, it works much
better for our guests.
It was working better earlier.
So pub.dartling.org is--
yes--
is our package hosting
service for Dart.
Is it online now?
OK.
Our guests at home can see it?
MALE SPEAKER 1: Yes.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
MALE SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
SETH LADD: OK, can you increase
the font a bunch?
So this is where you're going
to find all of our community
packages around Dart.
We've got MVC frameworks, we've
got utility libraries,
we have logging frameworks, not
only that, we also have
all the documentation as well.
How do you create your
own package?
How do you use a package?
If you were to click into a
certain package, you see
really nice set of metadata
around the description of the
package, the author, how you
contact the author, the
package's homepage, versions.
But I also like it on the right,
is a list of how do
you, yourself use a package.
Well, you can go through the
Dart Editor and actually, I'm
sorry, you can define your
dependencies for the packages
in your pubspec [INAUDIBLE]
file and then use Dart Editor to
actually run Pub and go get
all the packages for you.
Or of course, you can do
it on the command line.
All the instructions, all the
documentation, and the list of
community packages, they're
all on pub.dartlang.org.
You can find the stuff that
we've been talking about today
and some of the stuff our
community members
are working on there.
And we'll continue
fleshing it out.
And so I highly recommend
checking it out.
Cool.
So with that, let's meet some of
the authors behind some of
these packages that you can
find on pub.dartlang.org.
I want to hopefully go to the
Hangout here and welcome some
of our external guests.
So welcome everyone, Alex and
Kevin, thank you guys for
joining us.
And you might have--
oh, great, OK.
Alex.
KEVIN MOORE: Hey Seth.
SETH LADD: Hey Kevin,
thank you for--
Alex, let's start with you.
Could you introduce yourself?
How are you involved with
the Dart project?
ALEXANDER APRELEV: Right, so I
knew about Dart since it was
announced, since I've been
working on GWT applications
for a while.
And then I always wanted to work
closer with open source
projects, just to get a sense
of what it is like.
And then, this summer, when
my family was visiting our
grandparents, I had a lot of
time that I feel I could
spare, so I got the source
code for Dart, build it
locally, and basically the next
step was just to see what
I can [INAUDIBLE]
play with, get some hands
on experience with that.
And I was browsing through the
Dart blog, which is a website
where, let me share the page.
So actually the framework
around Dart is extremely
robust and easy to use.
Anyway, so, basically, when I
was building the Dart for Mac,
I saw that there was a problem
that I myself witnessed, and
then I saw that there's
was a bug actually
opened against that.
So I decided to investigate
that.
It was more along the lines of,
I have friends who do the
code [INAUDIBLE] partitions and
basically solve artificial
computer science problems.
I saw this as an opportunity to
solve something real that
could benefit the community,
the Dart community.
And I spent, like, on this
particular one, I spent only a
couple weeks, actually, looking
into the code, so the
description is just
straightforward, just the
build gets stuck.
And you can see people putting
all the thread
stack traces, et cetera.
But it turns out, after some
investigation, it turns out
that the issue was caused by
the xcode 4, explicitly
blocking signals, which actually
prevented Dart to
notice that the child
process exited.
So with that, I mean, initially,
I put this change
into the comments, but
then I took a little
bit to get the response.
No actually, yeah, so this one
was responded very quickly.
And then I thought that, all
right, let me make a next
step, which is actually
create a fix for this.
So this is all described--
so this is another, this is
another page that is part of
the development life cycle for
Dart, Chrome and code reviews.
So I created a patch, uploaded
it here, to the Chrome and
code reviews, have it reviewed
by Bill here, and Bill
committed it on my behalf.
I mean, I mean, it was something
that made sense to
the community.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
So this really speaks to Dart
being an open source project.
That is, you were able to file
bugs, view the bug tracker
itself, comment on the bugs,
and, in this case, actually
submit a patch and work with the
Dart engineers to get that
patch committed.
That's awesome.
ALEXANDER APRELEV:
Exactly right.
SETH LADD: But now
I think you're
doing a lot more, right?
So you've got the external
committer bit.
Is that true?
ALEXANDER APRELEV: True, true.
Yes, and I think after
I got about--
four changes.
Changes were committed, and
five were in the pipeline,
being reviewed, Peter
from [? Aarhus ?]
DartJS team just asked whether
I'm interested in having
external committers
access rights.
And I saw that as, OK, that's
another interesting angle,
that I want to see how it's done
in Dart team, the whole
build process, those
build [? blog ?]
website, which looks like
intriguing and scary.
I wanted to see what's it like
for you, and I got that.
And since then, I was really
shepherded and guided by Peter
and Dart to JS team.
And that's actually where I
spend most of my time in terms
of contributing to dart.
JJ BEHRENS: You know, when you
said that you fixed some weird
on Xcode involving signals,
I was impressed.
But when you said that Peter
approved of it, like, you are
on a whole other plane of
coolness to get Peter to
approve of anything.
SETH LADD: Yeah, the Dart to JS
is really, really good, and
I think it speaks to Alexander's
skills as well to
gain their respect.
JJ BEHRENS: Absolutely.
SETH LADD: But I also wanted to
say thanks to the Dart to
JS team for shepherding
external committers.
I think that's just fantastic
for them to open up a little
bit more and help get more
help and contributions.
So it's really cool to see this
two way collaboration.
JJ BEHRENS: Absolutely.
SETH LADD: So what are some of
the features or bugs you're
working on now for Dart to JS?
ALEXANDER APRELEV: So the most
recent one that we worked on
is actually improvements of the
internal implementation of
the way how the name resolution
is implemented.
It's not necessarily
visible directly.
That's actually another thing
that is extremely impressive--
team is not only focused on
delivering fixers and fixing
bugs, but also, at the same
time, cleaning up internals of
the engine, making sure that
everything is designed and
architected properly.
So that's in Dart to JS.
The most exciting bug that I
worked on recently involved a
Windows platform where there was
some weird problems with
the file being left
close by Dart.
It turns out that, once again,
the fix was very simple, but
it was something that, again,
took a little bit of research.
But that's exactly the kind of
adrenaline that I was looking
for and am looking for.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
Do you have any advice for
people who want to get more
involved with Dart, either at
the patch level, or for
developers who are interested in
getting external committer
access, like you did?
ALEXANDER APRELEV: So the whole
infrastructure, as I
mentioned, that is used
by Dart, starting from
[INAUDIBLE], Chromium code
review, build [? bot, ?]
these are all extremely
solid, extremely
robust pieces of software.
So the dartboard.com is the
excellent place to start in
terms of figuring out what's the
critical or high priority
bugs that Google team, Dart
team, needs help with.
So sort by criticality, by
priority, and identify the
area of an interest to you.
Like, I picked up Dart to JS
because I had some background
in parsing, and some of the
issues that I saw there seemed
pretty just straightforward
to me.
And putting aside
Mac build issue.
But yeah, look through the
bugs, identify something
that's of an interest to you,
and just go for it.
SETH LADD: So when they code
reviewed your changes, did you
get any feedback?
Did they ask you to
make any changes?
ALEXANDER APRELEV: Oh yeah,
yeah, that's actually--
code review process is something
that, generally
speaking, developers don't--
well, I don't know, I shouldn't
generalize.
But it's not really taken
very seriously.
But especially in Dart to JS
team, the amount of effort
that goes into code reviews--
it's exceptional.
You learn much more from
code reviews than
from anything else.
So of course, reading the source
code, but actually
doing the code review
is very useful.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I know that
at Google in general, we
really like code reviews.
But I think that that points out
something very important.
And that's that if you want
to contribute to the Dart
project, you have to be ready to
accept feedback, because no
matter what change you make,
whether you're on the team or
not on the team, people
are going to tell
you to make it better.
ALEXANDER APRELEV: Absolutely.
SETH LADD: It's definitely
part of the culture.
ALEXANDER APRELEV: Yeah,
and that's one thing
that I really enjoy.
I mean, personally, yeah, I
mean, one of the reasons why I
increased the amount of time
I spent on this is that I'm
learning a lot, for sure.
SETH LADD: Well, I liked
what you said--
find bugs or fixes that you
yourself are interested in.
And I think that's one of the
tenets of open source
development--
scratch your own itch.
And so, if you're interested in
working on or helping Dart,
find the area that interests you
and work on the thing that
gets you excited.
And that's probably the best
way you're going to be
successful.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yep.
ALEXANDER APRELEV:
That's right.
SETH LADD: Great, well
thank you, Alex.
We look forward to further
contributions and working with
you on Dart to JS and other
projects in Dart.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Awesome.
ALEXANDER APRELEV:
Sounds good.
SETH LADD: Let's say
hi to Kevin Moore.
Kevin is one of our early
adopters of Dart, and he's
been publishing libraries to
Pub, which we saw earlier.
And some of these libraries he
wants to show off today.
So hi Kevin, welcome
to the show.
KEVIN MOORE: Thanks Seth, thanks
for having me today.
SETH LADD: Oh, it's
our pleasure.
So Kevin, you've been working
on a bunch of stuff.
You've been working on "Pop,
Pop, Win" which is a great
HTML5 game built into
Dart that works
on mobile and desktop.
Oh, you just kicked off an
effort to explore what a build
system might look like, but I
think today we want to focus
on one of your other projects.
Let's start there.
What did you want to
show off today?
KEVIN MOORE: Today I want to
talk about the Bag of Tricks
that I call--
it's actually in the library
that I started.
I called a set of tools I built
at Microsoft when I was
there in 2005, 2006,
the bag of tricks.
And I realized it was a good
name for this general set of
tools and libraries
that I used.
In building systems, often you
want to encourage reuse, and
so it's something that I
certainly like to have when
I'm building software.
And obviously, with Pub out now,
it's really easy to share
that sort of stuff with
people in the wild.
So it's an interesting
collection of things.
I try to organize it well
internally, but it
does a lot of stuff.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Wow, cool.
SETH LADD: And I also have to
say that you have a great logo
for your project.
KEVIN MOORE: Oh, thank you.
Actually, I wonder if
I have it up here.
I wanted to talk about "Pop,
Pop, Win," but yeah, if you
wanted to take a look at
it, it's on github.
[? KevMu ?]
is my name, and it's box.dart,
so it's easy to find there.
And I must give credit to my
business partner, actually,
for doing the logo.
So I realized I started clicking
without clicking
share screen, so just
one second and I'll
show you the logo.
Just one second.
So thanks [? Robbie ?]
for the logo, and
here's the page on github.
I'm actively maintaining it.
It is on pub.
I try to be pretty explicit
about the version I'm on, the
version of Dart I'm on.
So actually, if you open up
the change log, mark down
file, you'll see that
if you align with--
[INAUDIBLE] right here.
So there's 2.0 branch in your
pub file, or the 2.0.2.1
aligns with the M1
build we call.
And then the releases since,
2.0.2.3 and 2.0.2.4, align
with, I think it was the last
major editor release, which is
not the most recent one,
but the one before.
I'm having some bugs with
the most recent one.
So something I'm really trying
to do here and encourage other
library authors is something
called semantic versioning.
And the idea is--
you might end up with more
releases than you want, I'm
staying kind of pre 1 until
Dart is released, but,
basically, every time I change
things, I try to increment the
build number so it's pretty
clear to people
if I've broken something.
SETH LADD: Cool, so Kevin, what
are some of the things
that BOT does?
KEVIN MOORE: So an example I
wanted to show quick was "Pop,
Pop, Win" was the game I wrote
or to show off Dart and do
some interesting things.
So quickly, I don't know if
you're hearing sounds, but--
ooh, and it blows up.
And so there's actually a lot of
stuff going on in the game
in terms of doing a lot of
drawing to canvas, allowing
interaction, you'll see the
mouse kind of changes.
And so really, what the
Bag of Tricks does--
it exposes the set of libraries
that let you build
interactive content on canvas.
That's actually one part
of the Bag of Tricks.
And so we're looking at the
source right now for BOT in
our Dart Editor.
And you'll see that I have the
retained library open.
So trying to follow the
guidelines that
exist in the libraries.
You see the retained bit, if
you want to import it,
includes a bunch of stuff,
things to do in canvas, and
clicking, doing basic visuals.
And so, if you want a simple
flavor, if you're looking at
the source code, a very
simple thing to play
would be the spin demo.
So we'll go to the example
folder and
run this one in Dartium.
Drum roll as Dartium loads, and
an error message because
we have slight version
conflicts.
This is what we get for having
a very fast moving build
process from the Dart team.
And so obviously, this looks
very simple, right?
But some of the interesting
things, because the canvas API
in HTML doesn't have any
notion of element.
It's [? just up ?] here
[? bit ?] buffer, you need to
work to add your own
event handling.
So if you notice, as I mouse
over here, we get an indicator
that the mouse is over this
rectangle, and the spinning
object is getting a
mouse over event.
And that's all features
I implemented
in the Bag of Tricks.
And so [INAUDIBLE]
elements, nested elements, and
do mouse interaction with
those elements.
SETH LADD: Kevin, I should say
that, for everyone watching at
home, it's very, very smooth.
It's just that it's a little
jittery on the Hangout.
So what Kevin sees is a very
smooth, spinning sphere.
KEVIN MOORE: Yeah, this is not
performance at all of Dart.
I would suggest people take a
look at "Pop, Pop, Win" if
they want to be convinced that
you can build very high
performance, high
quality games.
But unfortunately, this kind of
animation doesn't translate
well over the screen caps.
So my apologies for that.
So the retained library does
a bunch of that stuff.
I don't want to go
into it too much.
I'd actually point people to a
screen caps I did, I think it
was last week, that tried to
walk through how I built
retained and the things
that it does.
There's actually a set of other
features that are more
in the base libraries that
enable a lot of stuff.
And so if you click through,
and, actually, probably the
easiest thing to do, and also
to show off another feature
is, I'm using the documentation
generation that
exists in Dart, which I love.
I know Seth has pushed hard
to get this working well.
And so, if you kind of walk
through the APIs, it's all up
on BOTs, under my personal
website.
And this is actually linked
from the source code.
And so, really quickly, some
things that I built that
really helped me build the "Pop,
Pop, Win" game, there's
an array of 2D class, which
actually allows you to define
a two dimensional array
very efficiently.
So that's how I managed the
state of the field and,
actually, all the squares that
I'm drawing in the field.
I have classes for managing
different kinds of color, and
so I have hue, saturation,
and lightness color.
And where's the other
color here?
I'm just going to find it.
RGB's here somewhere.
There's RGB.
SETH LADD: Kevin.
KEVIN MOORE: Go ahead.
SETH LADD: So you showed
"Pop, Pop, Win" and
some spinning squares.
What are some other things
you envision people
using Dart to build?
Oh lord, the sky's the limit.
I'm actually having a lot of
fun right now building
interactive content.
JJ BEHRENS: Wait a second.
Did he just say that, like,
Dart is inappropriate for,
like, Mars Lander type
software because
the sky's the limit?
SETH LADD: If it runs
on the browser.
KEVIN MOORE: [INAUDIBLE]
I'd probably stick with
Go, if you're
doing embedded software.
But honestly, if you're doing
interactive content,
especially anything you want to
host on the web, I've built
things with Dart now that I've
dreamed about building, or I
would've built on a native
platform before.
And certainly, it's kind
of a dual evolution.
As the web platform has evolved
with Chrome, and you
can get really good interaction
with building
canvas apps and really fast
performance there--
so that gives you the
raw performance.
And then Dart has just been
spectacular because it really
lets you build large systems.
I've built large libraries with
deep object hierarchies
and deeply related
sets of objects.
And having a rich
object-oriented system, type
checking, that sort of stuff,
really makes it easy to build
more complicated things than I
normally would in JavaScript.
So it's actually been
really fun.
JJ BEHRENS: So Kevin, you've
obviously built a lot of
software in your career.
As you've come to Dart,
is there anything
different about Dart?
Are there lessons that you've
learned that have helped you
become more effective as
a Dart programmer?
KEVIN MOORE: Lessons
I've learned--
I think one of the big ones,
and this is discussed,
obviously, a lot, is kind of
embracing the optional
typeness of Dart.
And I think, like in so many
things in software, I find
that you'll find purists
in both extremes.
And so there's certainly people
who hate the notion of
using types, who think it's
gratuitous, since they don't
use it all.
And there's others who are
very strict about typing
everything.
And I'm probably actually more
to the latter, honestly.
I really like kind of using
types as much as possible,
just for my own kind
of sanity.
So certainly moving from a pure
JavaScript world, or even
a Ruby world, the two places
I've spent the most time, and
moving to this, I might start
out not using much typing as I
code, and then very quickly I'll
blend in more and more.
And the errors I get in the
Editor were good for a while,
and they're better every
release of the Editor.
So it really improves my
productivity, my ability to
refactor, my ability
to find bugs.
It's been really nice.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, so I've also
done a lot of product Ruby
programming.
As has Seth, and the one thing
I've noticed about programming
in Dart compared to Ruby is
that Ruby allows you to go
really, really fast, but then
when you hit a brick wall, it
really takes you a while to dig
yourself out of the hole.
Have you noticed this as well,
where you get stuck less often
because of the typing and
because it can catch errors
more quickly?
KEVIN MOORE: I think a lot of
the migration, at least I've
experienced moving from, because
I've built some big
systems in JavaScript
as well--
the fact that you don't have
this type handle to hold on to
can really get you in trouble.
You have to have an
insane amount of
diligence as you code in--
this is my experience, at
least, with Ruby, and
JavaScript, you need to have a
lot of diligence, not only for
your own code, but in the team
you're working with around
making sure you're documenting
things well, that you're not
overusing duck typing
because it really
can get you in trouble.
And you really have to write a
lot of tests just to make sure
that you're passing around the
right thing and that as the
code evolves, you're
not passing around
a type that's incorrect.
And so to have the flexibility
that I have in Ruby and
JavaScript around to be able to
move very quickly and not
worry about types as then kind
of prototyping, but being able
to flavor those on and load
those on, it's as much time as
it takes to, say, document
a method.
If you're running robust,
reusable code in Ruby or
JavaScript, you want to
document what you
expect as an input.
And so using an actual type,
as opposed to just a big
paragraph of text, really, not
only is it more clear to
documented, and easier for
tooling, it makes you more
productive because it's a much
more enforceable contract than
just a note that, oh, by the
way, I expect to get a
collection here, not a new
variable or something else.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
So you showed off some
of the 2D or graphics
capabilities of BOT.
Is there other utility things
that BOT does as well that
aren't just graphics related?
ALEXANDER APRELEV: Oh lord.
So a few examples, and I'll try
to go quick because it's
kind of a random collection
of things.
You'll notice here, property and
attachable actually have a
whole model for how you define
attachable events and
properties.
And so, I forget which design
pattern that enables.
The idea is, you can define a
very simple object and then,
at run time, add on new
attached behavior.
And so I'll give you an
example of this--
JJ BEHRENS: I think it's the
chain of responsibility.
KEVIN MOORE: Yeah, I think
that might map well.
These are always the
questions I bomb.
I know how to use the design
patterns, I just don't know
how to name them.
A good example here is how
I handle click handling.
So this is an example explicitly
about the visual
graphics stuff, but it
can be used anywhere.
The idea is, elements themselves
in my system don't
understand anything about hit
testing, don't understand
anything about the mouse.
But I could layer that on and
have events around attaching
click event, or attaching
a is clickable
attribute to an event.
So that you can tell, oh, you
want to add that functionality
after the fact?
I just turned on my screen
sharing to show you that I'm
looking at my documentation
here.
A few other things, I actually
have a model for events.
That's a little bit cleaner
if you're outside the DOM.
A lot of people wanted a unified
event model, and I'm
looking forward to that
getting sussed out.
So at the moment, it's a little
bit of a work around.
Hopefully, as the Dart team
comes to that, but it's easy
to figure out.
JJ BEHRENS: You know, I actually
think that that's a
really good feature because
I've been around
ActionScript 3 coders.
And one thing that they really
like to do is to have these
things that are on the stage,
and they love attaching custom
events to these things.
And so having a reusable model
where you could create your
own random events and attach
them to these objects, I think
that that's going
to be a big win.
SETH LADD: Kevin, can you
increase the font a bit as you
finish up the list here?
KEVIN MOORE: Sure.
And so there's a whole bunch
of random stuff here.
I won't go into all of it.
Take a look, [? pay ?]
[? me ?] and have to
answer questions.
And one of the more one-off
things I played with, but I
made it a library, I assume
you're looking at this now is,
I actually have a whole
library that
can generate QR codes.
And this is code
I borrowed from
another open source library.
I think it started out
as ActionScript.
But if you want to play with
an example of building a
canvas-based app, and using some
isolates, actually, and I
have a whole set of code that
actually makes dealing with
isolates much easier.
I have an example
of QR builder.
Can you guys see
my screen now?
SETH LADD: We can see
your screen, yes.
KEVIN MOORE: Awesome.
So quickly looking
up this sample.
It's always the demo gods that
get nervous when I'm on a live
[INAUDIBLE].
So here you see a QR code, and
it animates in, again, forgive
the frame rate on the Hangout,
but as you type in, you know,
you see that the QR code
updates in real time.
You can actually change the
error correction level and the
generation.
And actually, all the generation
is happening in the
background, in an isolate.
And I have whole set of helpers
in my async library
that makes basically, not really
binding, but attaching
to a value, and sending off
requests to get background
processed, and getting a
notification when that's done?
I simplified that pattern,
and created a set of
helpers to do that.
And so obviously, QR code
generation, even on a fast
machine, will slow down your
frame rate, but I use isolates
in the background, and
it's really fast.
And so even some of these simple
things have been very
easy to do in Dart and have
been a lot of fun.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
really neat.
I'm totally using it the next
time I interview some intern.
I'm going to be typing these
in real time and
asking him to read them.
[LAUGHTER]
JJ BEHRENS: I guarantee you,
some kid from MIT could do it.
SETH LADD: Awesome, well
thank you Kevin,
this is really cool.
I want to really encourage
everyone to check out BOT on
Pub and some of your other
projects as well.
"Pop, Pop, Win," the game that
you showed, is also open
source on github.
And thanks against for spending
time with us.
And we really appreciate you
working with the Dart
community like this and showing
off what it can do.
So thank you.
KEVIN MOORE: You're
so welcome.
SETH LADD: So we should move
from 2D graphics to 3D
graphics and talk to John.
John, thank you for
being here.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh
no, my pleasure.
SETH LADD: So John was a member
of one of the early
adopting communities of Dart and
really keyed off of what
he, again, kind of Kevin's
story as well, right?
Just wanting to be a little bit
more structured and take
advantage of a little bit more
power but yet build for the
modern web browser.
And now John, luckily,
works here.
And John's going to show off
some of the libraries that he
started before being a
Googler, and now he's
continued working
on at Google.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Hey everyone.
Yeah, very much like Kevin's
story, I was really attracted
to Dart, primarily for
the type system.
I come from a C++ background,
and I love type.
So I also kind of overly
type my code.
But it saves me a
lot of effort.
So what I want to show today is
a rendering engine and game
engine called Javelin.
So we definitely can't
see your fonts.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Wow, OK.
SETH LADD: And I don't think
increasing the font size will
help either.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Let me see
how the demo looks.
Eesh, it's so aliased.
JJ BEHRENS: It's much
smoother in person.
SETH LADD: Also, we have
a lot more pixels here.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, hold on.
All right, we're going to do
some technical rejiggering,
which is the technical term.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
So--
SETH LADD: While we're doing
this, why don't we talk a
little bit about your
background?
So you have experience
in actually
building and writing games.
Is that true?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Not so much
games, but like, kind of game
engine technology.
So I worked with Erwin
[? Kumons ?] on the Bullet
Physics engine for a couple
years, and kind of optimized
it for the PlayStation 3, and
then did a whole bunch of
smaller tool and technology
based work
for PlayStation titles.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
So you're very comfortable
deep in the low levels of
these engines.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, yes.
Far more comfortable down there
than a higher level.
So turn off--
and we can leave the
Hangout right?
JJ BEHRENS: So Seth, I've
noticed, a lot of the commits
that I've seen from John are
crazy low level, like, array
manipulations with like flow
32s to make them six times
faster, and they're written in
Assembly, and I'm like I
didn't even know this
stuff was in Dart.
And he's sitting here
patching it.
SETH LADD: Yeah it's
really cool.
And talk about where this
actually is happening-- this
is inside the Dart
virtual machine.
This is kind of the power of a
platform that has its own VM.
So of course, Dart compiles
the JavaScript, runs
everywhere, but if you have your
own virtual machine you
can accelerate options that
would be very hard to
accelerate in JavaScript,
like native access
to the typed arrays.
JJ BEHRENS: And I'm super
excited about the fact that
he's constantly running and
pushing the VM because the
VM's going to open up
some new doors.
SETH LADD: Right, just purely
performance reasons.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I'm really
excited as well.
This demo that I'm showing right
now is partially showing
off some of the work
I did to speed of
access to flow 32 arrays.
By the time it gets drawn, it's
into the slower arrays,
which will be going away soon,
but while it's been simulated,
it's running in these
fast arrays.
So what we're looking at here
is a fluid simulation.
It's a height filled based one,
so I can put a droplet in
there, and it's got reflective
boundaries.
So you can see that the waves
start reflecting back.
And this is running in a 50
by 50 grid all on the CPU.
None of this is being simulated
on the GPU.
It's pretty fun to play
around with--
SETH LADD: So of course, you
could do this in WebGL, and
get it on the GPU.
But you kind of alluded
to it earlier--
why do this on the CPU?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So the big
problem with something that
you simulate on WebGL is that if
you ever need to access it,
to animate it, or to interact
with it from the CPU, you
suffer a huge performance
penalty for that.
If you can do all of your work
entirely on the GPU, and the
work you're doing is well suited
to computation on a
grid, then it's much faster.
But as soon as you need to
involve the CPU, the
performance benefits very
quickly go away.
So this is all being simulated
on the CPU, and, as you can
see, I can kind of shoot off
a wave from the one side.
And it comes back and
reflects around.
SETH LADD: So what this is
actually running inside?
Because I think it's part of
the libraries you've been
working on.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
So internally to this demo,
I'm using two libraries.
The first is Dart vector math,
which is a 3D graphics, 3D
programming math library,
so it has a four by four
transformation matrices, all
the things that you need to
construct a 3D rendering
engine.
And that's also available
on Pub.
So definitely check it out if
you're doing any kind of 3D
programming.
One of the cool features of
Specter, a low level graphics
library that Javelin is built
on, is that it has a retained
mode debug drawing mechanism.
So what you're seeing on the
screen right now is a whole
bunch of coordinate systems, and
circles, and spheres, and
access line bounding boxes, but
they're being drawn in a
retained mode debug system.
So I can say, draw a box in this
position in the world for
two seconds and then
forget about it.
And Specter will handle drawing
it for the next two
seconds and then clearing it
from the debug system when the
time is up.
And so it supports lines, boxes,
spheres, circles, and
I'll be adding cones
and cylinders
support as well soon.
I just recently did a blog post
on the dartgamedevs.org
on how to use this.
It's really important, when
you're doing 3D graphics, to
have a debug drawing
mechanism.
SETH LADD: And I feel awful
for not mentioning
dartgamedevs.org on
our news updates.
Let's talk a little
bit about that.
What is that?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So it's a new
site that's focused on game
developers who are working
with Dart.
And we are taking
contributions from the community.
So far, I've written a few blog
posts on Specter, and I'm
going to have a couple more this
week, one of which will
be on how to do break
out like physics.
SETH LADD: Cool.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So another cool
feature here in Specter
is that I have a post processing
system, so all I
have to do is go down here and
select blur, and then suddenly
the entire scene is blurred.
The blurring is all being
done on the GPU.
It's really simple to add
new blur effects.
There's also a cloth
simulation.
Again, this is running entirely
on this CPU because
we want to be able to
throw things like a
sphere at the cloth.
So probably the most recent
feature that I've added to
Javelin is an entirely
data-driven scene.
So what you're looking at here
is a sky box, and there's a
few elements.
There's a box, and a cone, and
there's ground plane here, but
no code was written to
construct this scene.
And it can even animate.
So if I go in and I make a
change to this file here, I'm
changing a transformation
controller to manipulate the
box's translation.
So now that I've done that, if
I go down here, and I reload
the scene, you can see that the
box is now moving relative
to its parents.
And this is, again, I haven't
written any code, I don't have
to reload the application, I
just changed it, changed the
data file, and then asked
Specter to reload the scene
description.
SETH LADD: Now what is really
cool about something like
this, I know we've chatted about
this, is you can then
send out this configuration,
people can't fork it, change
it themselves, and kind of
branch these visuals demos.
And seeing how they might
propagate out in the wild is
really fascinating to me.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, that's the
ultimate goal with this.
And not so much just a scene
with transformations applied
objects, but also game
logic as well.
So hopefully you'll be able to
express most of the game just
through data, and then load it
up, and share it with friends,
and let them change it.
SETH LADD: So what are some
things that you'll be working
on next for these
two libraries?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So right now
it's mainly working on the
game component system so that
you can, kind of like Kevin's
attachable logic, and this is
coming from the ActionScript
world, where you have a
general game object.
And then you express its
behavior through a runtime
edition of components.
So you could say this game
object now has health.
And this game object
can have jump.
And this can all be expressed
through data.
So that's what the focus
right now is on.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
And this, of course, does this
compile the JavaScript to run
in other browsers?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It
should, yes.
SETH LADD: Browsers that have
WebGL, we should probably say.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, of course.
Yes.
SETH LADD: Which is Firefox,
Opera, and of course Chrome.
Well, thank you for
these demos.
And these are on Pub as well?
So Specter and Dart vector math,
as well as a user marker
based profiling system, are
all available on Pub.
Javelin is just on github right
now because it's still
pretty experimental, and we're
working out what the API
should look like.
So we don't want to promote it,
people to depend on it,
when we're going to change
a lot of it.
SETH LADD: It's still early.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
SETH LADD: Awesome, well, really
cool to see Pub has
some of the lower-level
features, and especially Dart
vector math, which is
useful to so many--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, not just
3D applications, but 2D
applications as well, the Dart
box to 2D port has a branch
that's almost complete that's
where they're moving over to
Dart vector math.
And it runs faster than
the current version.
SETH LADD: All right,
there you go.
Open source for the win.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
SETH LADD: Thank you John.
JJ BEHRENS: Awesome.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
Well, we have a couple
questions,
let's go into those.
Just a couple here for
our community today.
Chris McGee says, "What do you
think are the next big
milestones for Dart?"
JJ BEHRENS: I'm going
to take a big guess.
SETH LADD: OK.
JJ BEHRENS: Milestone 2.
SETH LADD: Ooh, nice.
M1 plus 1.
JJ BEHRENS: Well,
you know, yeah
SETH LADD: JJ has spoken.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah,
that's right.
SETH LADD: It will be M2.
I think I've heard--
what's that?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Sorry.
SETH LADD: I think I've heard
them talk about mix-ins.
JJ BEHRENS: Mix-ins,
also more mirrors.
There was another thing that
Claude mentioned at his most
recent talk in San Francisco.
But those are the
two big ones.
SETH LADD: Two big ones.
Yeah, and a lot of bug fixes.
JJ BEHRENS: A Lot of bug
fixes, and performance.
SETH LADD: Well, working
on the libraries.
JJ BEHRENS: Yep.
SETH LADD: Which has definitely
already started.
If you follow the mailing list,
there's been a ton of
"breaking change" emails.
We try to get a bunch of
those on the blog.
JJ BEHRENS: There's definitely
going to be more focus on the
libraries, whereas there was
more focused on the core
language itself previously.
Yeah.
SETH LADD: Cool, so good.
And thanks to the clean up,
actually, you can keep your
head above water a little bit,
thanks to the editor.
So another question here. "I
started coding with Dart, and
I see that it doesn't have good
compatibility with Firefox.
I really appreciate Dart.
My question is, what is
the solution to have
compatibility?"
Well, I think it's our intention
to support Firefox
just fine, including other
modern browsers like IE 9,
Opera, Safari, Firefox, Chrome,
mobile Safari, mobile
Chrome, and so we would
encourage you file bugs if you
notice any incompatibilities
between these different
browsers at dartbug.com/new.
And I mean, our general approach
here is that Dart,
when compiled to JavaScript,
should work great across all
modern browsers.
And so that definitely
includes Firefox.
So hopefully you can create a
reproducible test case for us.
We'll take a look at that.
I've already seen, for instance,
the HTML team take
these kind of issues very
seriously because
compatibility is, I would say,
maybe job number one.
That is, making Dart work across
modern browsers is
extremely important.
So hopefully we could fix
that bug for you.
JJ BEHRENS: Absolutely.
That's a critical thing for us
SETH LADD: Cool, well I want to
thank, again, our community
members, Alex and Kevin, thank
you for stopping by on this
show and talk how, Alex, you
see became an external
committer, and Kevin, how
you've been working on
external libraries--
very, very awesome.
We'll see you in Pub.
And John, thank you very much,
again, for demoing your
libraries that you've
working on.
Participate in Dart, join the
mailing list, file bugs.
Stack Overflow has a lot
of great questions.
And then publish your
libraries in Pub.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I
really want to point
out the Stack Overflow.
Because I'm sure that a lot of
people have questions about
Dart, but there's so many people
answering questions on
Dart that it's impossible for me
to get to Stack Overflow in
time for there to be a question
that's not answered.
SETH LADD: So pro-tip,
you can ask and then
answer your own question.
It's an awesome way
to get points.
But JJ's right, we have a
really good community.
JJ BEHRENS: We get paid
by commission, right?
Like we get paid by the number
of questions we answer.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Paid
by Stack Overflow.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SETH LADD: For you if you
put questions in for me.
JJ BEHRENS: I know.
Like, Seth answers the question
so fast, and if he
doesn't get to them,
Bob Nystrom does.
SETH LADD: I know.
There's some really good
community members that beat us
most of the time.
And we really appreciate that.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, we definitely
appreciate that.
That's a big win.
So we'll see you next on
"Dartisans" and in the Dart--